[Music]
bottom line up front again the 90 is
anywhere from 30 to 68.9% better than
the 5080 shouldn't I'm going to get
demonetized if I point it that way
that's at 4K gaming depending on the
game of course but the results are
commonly within that 45 to 55% range
against the 7900 XTX of a similar price
the 580 is within Striking Distance
often within 10% of each other as for
the 480 versus the 580 they're commonly
within 7 to 12% kind of boring and then
sometimes up to 20% but that gets you
the basics there's a ton more Nuance to
get into today if you just wanted those
expectations and you want to dip out
there you go see you in the next one but
otherwise we have a lot to get into for
thermals we have frequency validation
and then we also have some pretty
interesting efficiency testing where the
80 does actually prove itself in a
couple places in efficiency benchwork
specifically where because the power is
so much lower on this one than the 5090
uh it still benefits from that
generational uplift but it benefits even
more from the power coming down and
because of a formula of the two it looks
pretty good in those situations
sometimes the thermal testing for the
590 Fe was actually overall it was
really good for two slot card it
impressed us the 580 is a similar cooler
it looks identical for the most part but
there are some key differences first of
all no liquid metal it uses thermal
paste and then secondly there's some
changes to the heat sink itself we're
keeping this review really simple and
short and straightforward by our
standards today so let's just get right
into it before that this video is
brought to you by Arctic and the liquid
freezer 3 which we've tested using our
standard methodology and found to be one
of the most noise efficient CPU coolers
on our charts the liquid freezer 3
includes rise and offset mounting to
improve AMD performance and uses a
thicker radiator to further lower the
temperatures Arctic has pric these
competitively for aios and you can learn
more at the link in the description
below first up we have to disclose some
office gambling behind the scenes Jimmy
has bet Jeremy on the team that if the
80 can beat the 490 at any one benchmark
he's going to get some free tater tots
and I control the benchmarks that are
shown also my stomach just growled I
don't know if you could hear that that
actually that actually happened let's
quickly cover pricing so the 80 is a
$1,000 MSRP partner models are a little
higher than that in some situations uh
and the 509 is $2,000 for the MSRP they
launch at the same time which is January
30th and that puts the 580 at the same
price as the 480 super which had dropped
the price from the 480 the 5070 TI at
$750 and the570 at $550 will follow in
February pre-launch pricing on Best Buy
indicates that MSRP options will be slim
outside of nvidia's Founders Edition so
adjust your personal value assessment
based on what they actually show up for
on launch day we don't know we're
reviewing this before all of that comes
out the most expensive one that we can
see right now is
$1,400 so we'd say don't buy that one
the previous generation 480 launched at
$1,200 following the infamous unlaunch
of the 4802 GB which actually became the
470 TI more recently the 480 super
launched at $11,000 providing a value
increase despite its nearly
indistinguishable performance from the
base 480 the only reason it was
interesting was because of the price cut
am these radon 7900 XTX is the closest
competition that it has for the 580
currently the 7900 XTX starts as low as
$830 but it's more commonly around
$930 down from that is the 7900 XT
ranging from 650
to $710 and in a decidedly lower price
bracket AMD says its 970 series cards
will be arriving in March int gpus
haven't scaled up to this Market
category yet that's a hopeful yet for
the record but for now they're at the
lower end now for a quick overview of
the specs if you want more detail on the
specs you should check out our
announcement coverage of the card here
it's available in both a written format
and in a video but we'll go over the
basics again the Blackwell architecture
based RTX 580 has
10,752 Cuda cor and 16 GB of gddr 7 on a
256-bit bus these specs are way down
from the 590s configuration it's almost
exactly half making for probably the
biggest Gap that there's ever been
between the top two tiers on launch day
the RTX 580 is also a PCI gen5 card but
as our recent pcie scaling Benchmark
with the 5090 showed it barely makes a
difference at all in games to run on Gen
4 or even gen 3 this review will again
focus on high-end gpus and you can see
our test methodology on our site at
Gamers X . net we've got a link below
for the test bench information it's free
of third party ads it contains our game
settings and our test setup to see the
low end check out our Intel Arc b570
review as well time to get into my
favorite part for these cards which is
thermal testing now one of the cool
things we did for the 590 review if you
missed it was Scher and imaging where we
basically use a a parabolic lens a light
source and a camera to create Magic that
allowed us to image the air density
gradient uh around the card and all of
that applies to this c as well cuz the
Fe model for the 580 despite having some
key differences uh internally externally
the flow paths will be basically
identical so you check that out in the
590 review if you want to see how it
behaves but let's just get into the
thermal Benchmark numbers here's the
thermal chart under a full workload for
the GPU the RTX 58's temperature with
auto settings landed at 65 to 66° C for
the GPU considering the change to
thermal paste from liquid metal with the
founders edition cards the real impact
here to reduce the temperature is in the
power consumption reduction and we'll
look at that a little later RPM is
another part the memory temperature
plotted at about 72 to 75° for the 580
which is well within the TJ Maxx
restrictions of the memory on the card
should be about 105° for that as for the
580 fan speed it held about 1470 to 1500
RPM on this test that makes its acoustic
profile very similar to what we saw on
the 590 review so you can check that for
noise samples and a frequency spectrum
it's a little quieter overall the 590s
GPU temperature in this test was 72° C
with a 59s memory temperature at 90 we
weren't happy about that despite being
within spec cuz once it's in a hot box
case that 90° result becomes a concern
finally the 509s fan ran at about 100
RPM higher when left to its own devices
resulting in a 5080 Fe which despite
moving away from liquid metal uh is not
really at a disadvantage it's doing okay
overall especially because of the fact
that the power consumption is down
frequency validations up now this is
just to make sure the card is hitting at
least the specs set by Nvidia the RTX
580 clocks and this Benchmark held
relatively flat although not perfectly
flat at around 26 70 MHz nvidia's
website claims 2.62 GHz boost clock so
it's technically exceeding the minimum
spec the RTX 480 ran at about 2775 MHz
in this Benchmark consistent with what
we saw between the 590 and 490 the
frequency is higher on the 480 but the
architecture has changed and that's made
this an indirect comparison it's not all
about the frequency the RTX 590 bounces
around between 24 75 to 2670 MHz or so
mostly Landing below the 580 it's
relatively common for these Fuller
configurations to run lower clocks than
the lower spec parts uh but with higher
core counts instead and now time to get
into the gaming numbers we'll keep this
really fast and straightforward this
time because we just have a couple key
comparisons we want to repeatedly make
here and uh it's relatively simple so
let's get into those Final Fantasy 14's
up first and at 4K the 580 landed at 112
FPS average behind the RTX 490 is 139 FP
FPS average result and the 509s 182 FPS
average result so unfortunately for
Jimmy on our team he hasn't yet won the
BET from Jeremy this makes the 590
faster than the 580 by a massive 62% AMD
7900 XTX directly competes with the 580
but it does allow the 580 a lead of just
under 10 FPS in this Benchmark at this
resolution lows are about the same
between them against the 480 and the 480
super the 580 is about 15% better
generationally by name the 380 held a 71
FPS average in this Benchmark yielding a
58% uplift to the 580 the 280 TI's 54
FPS average gets basically doubled by
the 580 as a note some of these charts
have the 1070 The 1060 the 2060 and
other older cards on them you may find
interesting if you want that data at any
point in this review just pause on the
chart we won't be reading through them
all the 1080ti hasn't yet been rerun
this year at 1440p the RTX 580 held 2117
FPS average against the 590s 317 FPS
average we're not fully CPU bound here
yet so the 5090 still has a relatively
High scaling of 46% ahead of the 580 for
the same comparison the 490 led the 480
original by 36% and the super by
basically the same cuz they're basically
the same card the 7900 xdx remains neck
and neck with the 580 with the two
functionally identical from a player
experience standpoint they look the same
to you the 580 is technically ahead the
7900 XTX is the strongest competition
though to the 580 in the Riz test when
looking at pricing the 480 and the 480
super improved from about 200 FPS
average to 217 with a 580 or a
relatively boring 8 to 9% down the stack
we have the 7900 XT at 171 FPS average
the 4070 TI at 151 FPS average and the
6950 XT at 150 the generational
comparison to the 3080s 129 FPS average
gives the 80 a 68% Improvement a bit
better than observed at 4K finally for
Final Fantasy the final resolution is
1080P and that has the 5 90 at the same
impressive 407 FPS number that we
mentioned last week with the 580 at 302
FPS average now despite the heavier CP
load at this resolution the advantage
remains 35% for the 590 over the 580
still that's nothing compared to what we
saw at 4K the 490 leads the 580 by 24%
at 376 FPS average to 302 the 700 XTX is
closer than ever to the 580 and is tied
and all practical senses it's looking
good here especially with the price but
this ignores rate tracing testing that
tends to still favor Nvidia let's move
on black myth is up next tested first at
4K and rasterized this is a heavy
workload for these cards the 590 at 86
FPS average and holding strong for frame
time pacing as indicated by the 1% and0
1% lows the RTX 490 is next at 67 FPS
average followed by the 580 at 58 FPS
average this has the 490 as 16% better
than the 580 and the 590 as 48% better
than the 580 the RTX 480 super and 480
are functionally identical and give the
580 an underwhelming 6fps lead which is
about 12% here the 580 leads the 700 XTX
by 177% with amd's card falling
disproportionately behind in this test
with its 49 FPS result lows on the 7800
XTX are commendable though and show
impressive consistency strong prior gen
cards include the 390 TI at 45 FPS
average and 380 at 36.6 FPS average with
the 380 yielding an uplift of 57% to the
580 and similar for the 6950 XT at 1840p
the RTX 590 leads the chart at 130 FPS
average making it 23% better than the
490 and 34% better than the 580 these
numbers for the 490 comparison are down
compared to 4K like we talked about in
the 590 review the 580 and 480 are
disappointingly close at only 9%
Improvement for the 580 the lead over
the 7800 XTX also reduces down to 133%
here with lower resolution drawing them
closer noteworthy other cards include
the 390 TI at 74 FPS average the 700 XT
at 71 FPS average which isn't bad
considering its price at various points
in history the 380 at 62 FPS average and
the 280 TI at 45 FPS average scaling
continued at 1080p where the 590 boosts
to 160 FPS average from the 130 FPS
result at 1440p the 580 still Trails the
490 but they get close and the 490s
advantage is reduced to 6% that's just 6
percentage points away from victory for
Jimmy on the team generationally the 580
leads the 480 by 7% down from its lead
of 9% at 1440p and 12% at 4K the 700 xdx
still Trails by about 10 FPS here it's a
shame that AMD decided not to compete at
the high on this generation from what
they say at least because a generational
step over the current XTX might have
been a serious Contender to the 80
there's still time but let's move on
Starfield is up at 4K first we have to
address this absolute roast of a comment
from our 590 review and this one this
one I read a few times made me laugh
leave more like it it said quote I would
like to correct one mistake GN made in
this review where they stated that there
aren't many reasons to play Starfield at
1080p but in actuality there aren't many
reasons to play this game at all end
quote ouch well uh anyway at 4K the RTX
590 held 18 FPS average and led the 580
by 41% not the best we've seen but still
a large gap for reference the 4090 is 92
FPS average led the 480 71 FPS by 30%
comparatively that makes the gap between
the last generation 90 and 80 class
cards smaller than the current
generation in this game against the 480
the 580 is about 5 FPS improved that's
not very exciting and video's angle will
probably be pricing here the 7800 xdx
actually defeats the 580 on a
technicality in this one as well with
frame time pacing equivalent between
them and the average FPS functionally
identical there's no perceptible
difference between these which is a
benefit to the 7800 XTX in this
rasterized scenario at 1440p the 590
climbs to 147 FPS average and leads the
580 is 110 FPS result by 34% that
reduces the lead versus 4K the 700 XTX
also climbs with a very slight but
irrelevant victory over the 5080 with
lows identical when round it against the
nearly perfectly matched 480 and 480
super the 580 holds an unimpressive 2
and a half% lead wow that's really worth
benchmarking other cards worth
highlighting include the 380 ftw3 riy GA
at 72 FPS average and the 2080 TI at 50
FPS AMD 700 XT is also noteworthy for
its performance when considering some of
its historical pricing at 1080p the RTX
580 is 132 FPS average gives the 490 a
lead of 177% and the 590 a lead of 24%
the 580 matches the 480 equally here
with the 480 super within error just
like its entire pointless existence sort
of like Starfield at 1080p back at you
commenter the XTX also nearly equals the
580 Al Nvidia has an advantage on a
technicality let's move on Dragon Dogma
2 is up now first at 4K rasterized say
something about this game in the
comments see if it gets in the next one
the RTX 590 ran at 133 FPS average and
held well paced lows behind it its lead
over the 490s 98 FPS average is 35% here
with the lead over the 5080 at 57% this
is one of the largest gaps thus far so
for comparison the 490 led the 480 nons
super by 36% meaning that the 490 and
480 were closer together to each other
than the 90 and 80 are to each other the
700 XTX is 77 FPS average has it
outperforming the 4080 cards and behind
the 80 card which leads by 10% the 380
did okay in this test at 50 FPS average
it's not bad for the uh relative age on
the card still pretty new though with a
71% Improvement jumping to the 80 1440p
has the 580 at 134 FPS average achieving
71% of the performance of the 5090 at
about 50% of the price the RTX 490 leads
the 580 again this time around 20 FPS as
for AMD the 7800 XTX lands at 126 FPS
average for a 10 FPS gap between the two
cards the 4080 lands at 122 FPS average
keeping the 580 at 10% ahead 1080p has
the cards crushed together although
there's still a gap of 49 FPS between
the 590 and 580 that's 30% which is a
lot for 1080p but this isn't necessarily
a scenario to plan for the RTX 480 is
right next to the 580 although the Gap
is 10 FP average the reality is that
very few people would notice the
difference between these two sets of
numbers in this particular game this is
where we would test cyberpunk Phantom
Liberty if it worked we've had repeat
issues with getting the 50 Series cards
to run cyberp Punk without some sort of
game level issue occurring where
sometimes it just won't launch or it
crashes we had this with the 5090 but we
reinstalled the game wiped all of its
local data and that fixed it we can't
state for certain that it is a fault of
the 50 Series cards and not some other
game update especially because c punk
has had so many problems over the years
but what we can say is that it
continuously kept breaking so we removed
it from this review until the game is
more stable it just it was crashing or
it wasn't launching we tried to fix it a
few times and there's just no no point
in testing a broken game or at least a
broken game on these cards so we'll look
into this more later potentially but for
now because we're not sure if it's
Unique to the 50 Series or not and
because we know Jay had a similar issue
in his testing we're just going to move
on d light 2 at 4K is next the 580 ran
at 81 FPS average giving the 490 a 133%
lead and the 590 a 56% lead that's a
large Improvement for the 590 over the
580 the 490 improved over the 480 by
less at 36% here the 580 leads the 7900
XTX by 12% with the 7900 XTX is 73 FPS
average result Landing between the 580
and the 480 speaking of the 580 leads
the 480 cards by about 21% we're seeing
large gains from the 380 to the 580 as
expected with a 280 TI below even the
380 at 1440p the RTX 80 is 149 FPS
average puts it close to the 700 XTX is
141 with lows between them also
comparable the 580 is advantaged but
that Gap was larger at 4K the 590 also
has its lead cut down to 45% although
still significant the doubled price with
the 590 jeopardizes its value for anyone
not using it in vram intensive work
scenarios the 480 cards were again
almost identical reproving why we didn't
waste our time in that review the 580
leads them by 12% at 1080p the 590 LED
the 580 by 44% which is really more
impressive for the 9800 xvd than
anything else it's genuinely really
exciting from a CPU standpoint there a
GP review but man the 9800 xpd continues
to impress this is a gigantic Gap when
considering how any prior CPU we've used
for these benches would be bottlenecking
the top two three cards at this point
the 490 maintains a lead of 19% here
over the 580 in Resident Evil 4 at 4K
the 580 fell behind the 7800 XTX by 4
FPS lows are about the same but
advantaged on the 7900 XTX the 59s lead
over the 580 is massive in this one at
68.9% with these settings it's a huge
Gulf and looking back the 490 led the
480 by 47% there are two main ways to
look at this one is that the 590 is just
that good or two the 580 is just that
unimpressive to figure out which it is
we can compare the 580 to the 480 the
Improvement here is 19% nvidia's best
argument for itself will be the price as
compared to the original 480 and the
7900 XTX wins that argument in this
particular game though at 1440p the
advantage in the 590 or the 580 is
reduced to 56% it's still a lot though
the 490 is still more than 50 frames per
second faster than the 580 with the 700
XTX now 4% ahead it's not a huge gap but
considering the generational difference
and the price of the XTX here we remain
disappointed that AMD has signaled it
likely won't launch a replacement this
generation maybe they'll reconsider the
580 is lead over the 480 drops to just
11% here we're on to Ray tracing testing
now and Blackmouth won is up first with
a caveat that this game is unbelievably
Nvidia favored we have other tests for
RT that are more balanced but this one
is one of the heaviest workloads and it
also happens to benefit Nvidia cyber
Punk would also fit that bill if it
worked but we removed it for stability
issues that we mentioned earlier at 4K
with fsar as defined in the chart title
the 590 held 88 FPS average and the 490
ran at 65 FPS average the 80 ran at 59
FPS average and that sets a 15% lead
over the 480 Fe is 51 FPS average some
notable here the 380 just can't really
handle these settings and it's down at
28 FPS average jumping to the 480 from
the 380 would be an 83% uplift in this
test with the 580 giving an uplift of
112% total from the 380 sadly the 7800
XTX is worse than the 380 in this
Benchmark and as for the 90 it ran 51%
higher frame rate than the 580 with
these conditions sadly for Jimmy though
the 580 did not defeat the 490 here but
there's Hope by presenting a 1080p chart
with FSR we were able to let Jimmy win
the 580 operated at 122 FPS average and
what's that the 80 outperforms the 490
in this one by 1.5 FPS average you're
welcome Jimmy no one said that the win
had to be meaningful and a win is a win
tater tots are still tater tots as soon
as I reported the results to the team
though it sounded like there was a
rematch for the 5070 so we'll look
forward to that the 80 roughly matches
the 490 in this result with the 5090
leading the 580 by 30% the 1080p
restriction with FSR is what's making
these less exciting than typically
except for the factor of the BET over
the tater tots Dragon Dogma 2 with rt is
up next this one is more balanced the
RTX 590 at 4K ran at 113 FPS average
with maximum RT which puts it 33% over
the 490 and 57% over the 580 the 7800
XTX is much more competitive in this one
than black myth running at 66 FPS
average and Landing between the 480
super and the 580 the generational
uplift is 16% from the 480 Fe to the 580
Fe here at 1440p with rt the 580 held
about a 7% lead over the 7900 XTX it's
not bad for amd's last gen card in this
game as for the 480 Fe the 580 is about
10% ahead not very exciting for NVIDIA
it's a side grade uh 58s is kind of
boring in this one so let's move on at
1080p the 580s 146 FPS average had it
only about 9 FPS over the 480 the 590
still keeps a 33% lead over the 580
despite slimming down versus the 4K
results 57% Gap it's not interesting
let's skip ahead with raate tracing for
d light 2 and tested at 4K and upscaling
the 580 ran at 67 FPS average and
trailed the 490 by over 10 FPS the 590
led the 580 by 63% here it's a lot over
the 480 the 80 leads by about 177% the
700 XTX is between the 390 TI and 4070
TI trailing the 480 and obviously
therefore trailing the 580 at 14 40p
with rt and upscaling the 580 is 117 FPS
average lands at 12% ahead of the 480
the Gap is shrinking here the 7800 XTX
Trails somewhat significantly and gives
the 580 an advantage of 35% at 1080p the
590 proves that there's still Headroom
in the CPU impressively with its 224 FPS
average leading the 580 by 41% but the
480 and 580 get squished together with
only a 9% advantage to the 580 between
them the 700 XTX is closer to the 3090
TI here keeping the 580 about 30% ahead
finally for RT Resident Evil 4 at 4K
with upscaling is up the RTX 590 ran at
210 FPS average with these settings or a
54% improvement over the 80s 136 the 700
XCX is much more competitive here than
some of the others with the title
generally being a lightweight RT
implementation we keep it around for
that reason we have one heavy title like
black myth and it helps to keep balance
and represent with a lighter one the
7800 XTX looks much better here than in
the other RT tests and the 4080 is 117
to 19 FPS average makes the scaling in
the 580 overall boring unfortunately
with the Improvement being hardly
noticeable here's 1440p the 580 jumps to
205 FPS average the 590 to 290 FPS
average and the 7800 XTX to 195 the XTX
is still competitive here especially
given the price and generational
differences likewise the 4080 still
makes the 80 relatively uninteresting so
feels like a side grade once again power
efficiency testing is next measured
using power interposers and capturing
only GPU power we're not measuring total
system power for this and instead
isolate for the GPU the pcie slot is
intercepted and measured as well idle
power consumption is far better on the
580 than the 590 keep in mind that idle
power testing is very situational to the
monitor the counter monitors refresh
rate power plans but our test setup is
identical unit to unit so that's all
that matters here they're all under the
same conditions under these conditions
the 5080 was at 12.75 watt when idle on
desktop this is close but improved upon
the 480s 15 to 16 Watt power drop both
of which are far below the 490s 29 Watt
and 590s 46 Watts now for the efficiency
this is a calculation of FPS and power
so having a lower power and a higher FPS
will result in the best number here
Final Fantasy 14 at 4K had the 80 at the
top of the chart for efficiency
comparatively this is a great result
it's 298 watt draw here leaves Headroom
in the TDP budget with relatively High
frame rate enabling it to outperform the
269 watt 480 super for efficiency and
performance alike it also outdoes the
5090 which scored 0.34 FPS per watt the
580 significantly outdoes the rx700 XTX
which ran at 0.24 FPS per watt and 430
Watts this appears to be a possible
strong point for the 580 1440p gives us
a lot more cards on the chart since
we've tested more mid-range devices this
generation but with the downside that
the high-end devices scale their bad at
4K that means that we lose some of the
frame rate scaling Advantage they might
have the 580 is still tied for the most
efficient on this chart after rounding
aligning with the 480 super as the most
efficient GPU we've tested yet it's at
0.75 FPS per watt while pulling 290
Watts up from 268 watts of the 480 super
but also up in frame rate the 490 pulled
386 Watts here with the 590 at 520 for
efficiency in f124 at 4K and with rt the
RTX 580 ties the 490 and is within
reasonable variance of the 490 and 480
super results the 580 pulled 330 watts
in this test putting it notably lower in
power consumption than the 590's 569
watt draw here but still more than the
4080 sup 291 Watts the 7800 XTX is
significantly less efficient in this
particular workload hampered in part by
RT but also just by its 422 watt draw
asra extras coming up we still have a
lot of testing with ITX cases so we're
testing specifically the Fe dual flowr
design in ITX cases cuz we want to see
how this does pushing air straight
through the card when there are small
situations to work with so that's coming
up we also have transient power tests
coming up that's looking at Power
excursions to see how big are the spikes
we also have a video about MFG or
multiframe generation that is almost
100% complete it will probably go up
tomorrow we'll see uh when this video
goes live but that is coming up that
delves into nvidia's new dlss and frame
generation technology which is going to
be important to talk about because they
won won't stop talking about it and it's
what's caused some of the marketing pain
for some of these cards so otherwise
that's all all the numbers in this
review let's just do the quick recap
first thermals on the 580 Fe cooler are
good overall and the acoustic profile is
similar to the 590 Fe cooler it's
actually a little bit quieter you can
check out our 590 Fe review for that and
for the frequency spectrum plot we think
the Fe cooler execution on the 580
remains good like was pretty good on the
5090 and this is just a lower power card
it works better here even though they
don't have liquid metal and they've gone
with a a cheaper heat snc solution that
we'll talk about in possibly a tear down
the efficiency is toward the top end of
the charts and the card seems to be more
within the optimal power range than the
590 for gaming performance this is one
of the largest gaps we've seen between
the top two cards the 590 leads the 5080
anywhere from 30% to nearly 70% 4K
Benchmark results the 80 is relatively
boring uplift over the 4080
unfortunately but this want me why
Nvidia is pushing MFG so hard the 7800
XTX is a strong competitor in
rasterization but it is aailable in R
tracing finally the low vram capacity
continues to be an unfortunate way to
segment the 90 class Cards into a sort
of professional users Camp the 580 being
a 16 GB device destroys its usefulness
for at least us for things like Adobe
Premiere and blender rendering where we
really use the vram here uh that
actually makes the 3090 TI more useful
to us than the 80s as an example but
that's probably the plan to drive 590
sales unfortunately the 490 cards have
largely evaporated or there might be a
Strawn argument for them still with that
vram boost there were several partner
models at $1,200 to $1,400 in the
pre-launch listing $1,400 is insane to
pay do not pay $1,400 for a 580 there
like a 40% increase over the MSRP uh
that is not worth it and the value is
absolutely not there for that much money
the $1,200 models are also suspect and
actually uh the ,000 ones the value just
isn't that compelling either so uh
unfortunately this is just how nvidia's
position these cars where they're
creating such a gap between the highest
end the next one down these days that uh
it's just it's clear segmentation
but there's room to put something in the
middle like a 80 TI or something and we
also continue to take issue with and
we'll continue to talk about and video's
massively misleading
marketing performance chart that we
talked about the 590 review the 580 is
back for that it's shown as being 2x the
speed of a 480 in several tests that's
interesting we didn't see that anywhere
but again this has to do with its MFG 4X
mode that once again is still basically
the same color as the background when
you look at the footer text for the
chart that actually discloses what's
going on and we're testing that we have
thoughts on it the boring range of 10%
to maybe 20% in some situations is more
common but as for MFG itself again we
have full benchmarks on that and we also
have as part of that video a huge
discussion on why nvidia's knowledge is
very out of date on present modon so
we'll talk about that in that video uh
this is why though Nvidia is pushing MFG
so hard the 80 without it would look
like an incredibly boring product
generationally uh with maybe some
exception for the efficiency Behavior
but the Gap is sometimes like 10 FPS
versus a 480 super at the same price uh
and it's just too hard to get excited
about with that so seems like a tool to
create 590 sales really more than
anything El as for the bats of tater
tots within the office it looks like
Jimmy wins this one but I've already
been informed that there's a rematch for
the 5070 versus the 490 claims because
who would get up on Ag and say something
like okay so 5070 490 performance
$549 other than the CEO of Nvidia I mean
who who would do that that's the 80
review we kept it simple for this one
you've got all the charts and numbers to
make your decision we have a lot more
benchmarks coming up for everything else
that's launching so they've got two more
cards AMD has the RX 970 and 970 XT that
should be launching in March
unfortunately looking at the 700 XTX
results here uh it sounds like AMD
is not launching a replacement for that
car this generation which is just kind
of a shame because that means there's no
competition the high end of the market
and based on these numbers maybe there
would have been space for them but we'll
see what they do anyway in March we'll
be reviewing those and then we've got
the Intel Arc b580 and b57 reviews up if
you want to look at something that's in
the cheaper end of things uh those are
they're actually relatively competitive
for Intel's positioning right now so
that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe more you can go to
store. Gamers access.net if you want to
support our reviews process and our
testing or you can go to patreon.com
Gamers Nexus to throw a few bucks our
way to continue the efforts of what
we're doing subscribe for the rest and
we'll see you all next time